bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
7,8 débat ce soir plus de terrain en
plus de liens avec la population la
fameuse police de sécurité du quotidien
promesses de campagne d'emmanuel macron
se dessine une grande concertation sur
le sujet a été lancé gérard collomb
ministre de l'intérieur en a dévoilé les
contours fin octobre mais que penser de
cette nouvelle police de sécurité
quotidienne
à quels besoins va-t-elle répondre
doit-on la parenté à l'ancienne police
de proximité
symbole de la politique sécuritaire de
lionel jospin à quoi s'attendre c'est le
débat du jour en plateau ce soir avec
nous julien le cam secrétaire régional
adjoint du syndicat de police alliance
dans les yvelines et didier baichère
député la république en marche de la
première circonscription des yvelines
bonsoir à tous les deux points bienvenus
bon alors je me tourne vers vous julien
l'uqam vous pensez quoi de cette future
prochaine police et sécurité du
quotidien est ce que ça va dans le bon
sens pour vous or pour l'instant on n'a
pas eu encore le détail effectivement on
est reçue la semaine prochaine en
préfecture pour avoir le débat avec
monsieur le préfet des différents élus
pour justement parler de ceux de
l'application de cette police de
sécurité du quotidien nous au niveau des
syndicats on est
on est assez on est on sait réserver en
fin de compte un parce que nous on il
faut savoir que la police actuellement
sur 78 et une police malade
donc effectivement c'est de nous il faut
savoir que sur le département
actuellement on ferme des structures
voilà on supprime des postes depuis
plusieurs années donc effectivement on
est un peu surpris un peu cet effet
d'annonce
deux créations d'éventuellement d'unités
supplémentaires alors qu'effectivement
on a du mal à faire tourner les
commissariats actuellement 10es pêcheurs
à vous c'est des choses qui sont prises
en compte justement pour pour appliquer
cette cette police de sécurité
du coup du quotidien justement sur les
difficultés à ce que je crois c'est
qu'on est on est parti du constat que
monsieur décrit tout simplement c'est si
on ordonne peut-être deux trois grands
chiffres 1 pour savoir de quoi on parle
le budget de la de la police de manière
générale à la sécurité intérieure
c'est plus de 13 milliards d'euros il va
être en augmentation à partir de 2018 et
sanctuariser pendant l'ensemble du
quinquennat donc de +1 9%
donc ça fait très nombreuses années que
ce n'est pas arrivé on parle de dix
mille policiers supplémentaires et je
pense qu'on est parti de ce constat qu'à
un moment donné on veut pas forcément
plus de sécurité ou plus de répression
on veut une police mieux organisés avec
plus de moyens donc la police de
sécurité quotidienne comme vous le
disais vous le disiez la concertation va
commencer à partir de la semaine
prochaine parce que c'est pas quelque
chose qui est décidé dans un ministère
c'est un engagement de campagne mais on
va partir sur le terrain donc il ya deux
cent cinquante mille questionnaires qui
sont partis auprès de l'ensemble des
policiers et gendarmes pour recevoir
recueillir leurs avis sur sur le sujet
et il ya cette concertation qui démarre
cette semaine pour les soixante dix huit
c'est la concertation avec la police la
gendarmerie mais également les bailleurs
sociaux les associations et l'ensemble
des élus du territoire donc on va tous
se mettre autour de la table pour savoir
avec plus de moyens comment on veut
s'organiser et vous savez très bien que
d'un territoire à l'autre
la police va voir une mission
extrêmement différentes
voilà c'est ça parce qu'on parle de
police sur le terrain de recréer à de
recréer un lien avec la population donc
justement les de la population sera
t-elle 13 en course dans cette
concertation à travers les associations
bien sûr les saisons de riverains a bien
bien bien entendu et ça on le verra
partir de de la semaine la semaine qui
s'annonce
je crois que il faut aussi avoir en tête
que cette police de proximité
quotidienne elle arrivera en même temps
que la réflexion sur les moyens nouveaux
pour la justice parce qu'on l'entend
souvent et moins quand j'ai rencontré
aussi bien des syndicats de policiers
mais aussi les les différents
commissariats de mon territoire
on entend qu'il ya de la désorganisation
et que c'est pas forcément plus de
moyens qui sont nécessaires c'est aussi
des moyens pour agir différents on a
parlé de comment donner les moyens de
donner des amendes peut-être financières
directement par les policiers donc plus
de policiers mais c'est aussi une
restructuration des moyens qu'ils ont
pour pouvoir agir sur le terrain et ça
c'est extrêmement important
je viens le cam sur les moyens justement
vous entendez est ce que pour vous ces
essais c'est une mesure certains
dispositifs karima on avait besoin de
matériel urgent il faut savoir quand il
ya un manque de moyens là dernièrement
il faut savoir que la bac de versailles
et n'avait plus de véhicules banalisés
pour patrouiller
ils ont dû prendre des véhicules
sérigraphiés faut savoir qu'il ya pour
nous c'est comme si le système était en
faillite il n'y a plus de véhicules de
remplacement on manque d'effectifs
il faut savoir que là on vient de subir
une réforme des horaires dans la
profession nous on essaye nous les
conditions de travail des policiers
c'est notre inquiétude de la voilà il
faut savoir que la réforme horaire nous
ce qu'on souhaite c'est que les
policiers et un week-end sur deux de
repos faut savoir qu'actuellement ils
ont qu un seul week-end sur six donc si
vous voulez de créer des psq des
nouvelles unités c'est pas forcément la
priorité dans la profession on en est à
notre 40e suicide dans la profession
depuis le début de l'année il faut
savoir que nous les syndicats on tire la
sonnette d'alarmé ce sujet alors
effectivement c'est très bien de créer
des psq des nouvelles polices de radio
se rapprocher de la population on n'est
pas loin de la population on la voit
tous les jours à mes collègues en
patrouille la croise tous les jours et
va à sa rencontre tous les jours donc on
a besoin d'effectifs supplémentaires
parce que effectivement créer des
nouvelles unités sans effectifs
supplémentaires c'est impossible
et quand on quand vous entendez parler
d'une police sur mesure avec à travers
cette police de sécurité du quotidien
une police plus connectés alors plus
connecté il faut savoir que la semaine
dernière j'ai remplir j'ai rencontré
l'enquêteur de la cybercriminalité de la
sûreté départementale 10
in on lui a coupé l'adsl parce que la
ddsp ne payez plus orange
donc si vous voulez on parle d'une
police connectés voyez on en est à un
point mes collègues enquêteurs
cybercrime n'ont même pas d'adsl
donc si vous laisser on est vraiment
très loin en fait des annonces faites
tant mieux si on a des tablettes
connectées cette fois ci tant mieux non
son on attend que ça si ça tombe bien
c'est la période du budget donc on a
voté la semaine dernière le budget de la
sécurité nationale donc je le disais en
introduction
donc s'ils augmentent de 1,9 pour cent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait danser 1,9 pour
cent d'augmentation donc plus 1 29 %
versus le budget 13 plus de 13 milliards
trois cent mille euros vont être
consacrés à la rénovation immobilière
parce que vous voulez pas des deux
voulaient pas cité dans votre propos
mais il ya une nécessité jeu
pour avoir visité plusieurs fois le
commissariat de versailles il ya
vraiment une nécessité de remettre en
état un certain nombre de casernes sur
deux casernes pardon de deux
commissariats sur sur nos sur notre
territoire dont 300 millions pour ça
c'est sur l'ensemble du plan sur les
cinq années trente mille véhicules qui
vont être commandés 115000 tablette pour
l'ensemble des policiers et des
gendarmes
quand on dit une police différente plus
connectés avec la population c'est aussi
au sens numérique du terme
si on veut gagner du temps pour que les
policiers soient sur le terrain en
dialogue avec la population encore une
fois on ne cherche pas que la répression
je pense que c'est important d'insister
sûr ce point là on cherche à créer de du
dialogue et de la revalorisation de la
profession sur le terrain il faut que
d'autres mesures
tous les papiers qui sont remplies
allons à longueur de journée soit
simplifiée et donc numériser la police
leur donner des tablettes typiquement
pour faire un certain nombre de choses
directement il pas avoir recopié plein
de fois les les documents c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement important et
c'est prévu dans le cadre justement
comment est-ce qu'on restaure la
confiance entre police et citoyen
comment casser cette logique palpable de
confrontation police citoyens moi je dis
ceci est peut-être deux choses
confrontation déjà je n'ai pas le
sentiment que les françaises et les
français de manière générale
on apprenait que leur police au
contraire quand on regarde les sondages
qui sont faits il ya vraiment un
attachement extrêmement fort à la police
ou à la gendarmerie donc ça c'est une
première chose après que sur certains
territoires y ait de l'affrontement
parce qu'il ya des difficultés sociales
ou autres historiques ou pas d'ailleurs
c'est une réalité aussi mais je pense
qu'on peut pas généraliser par rapport à
ces affrontements qui peuvent être dans
certains quartiers à certains endroits à
l'ensemble de la population france alors
justement sur ces quartiers quartiers
dits sensibles place la police de
sécurité du quotidien mattel s'associer
peut-être aux éducateurs de quartier aux
associations est ce que c'est le rôle de
la police de s'associer à ces à ces
personnes oui c'est vrai que de prendre
contact avec les différents intervenants
sur le terrain oui ça peut être une
possibilité pour mes collègues en
patrouille le problème c'est qu'on en
est à un point où justement il ya des
week-ends où nous n'avons plus de
patrouilles à mettre sur le terrain
en fait on a un tel manque d'effectif
que même de parfois monter une
patrouille de trois fonctionnaires ce
qui est préconisé dans les textes on a
du mal il ya forcément des fois une
patrouille de deux donc nous
d'intervenir dans les quartiers les
collègues le font mais il faut aussi
redonner aux collègues de d'avoir un
moyen de faire leur travail il faut
savoir qu'il ya eu un fléau cet été
c'était le fléau des motocross
on a un exemple typique c'est à dire que
nous la consigne qui a été donnée à nos
qu'on annonce nos collègues c'est de ne
pas intervenir sur ces interventions
pour l'on a interdit de prendre
interdiction de prendre en charge ces
véhicules donc il ya aussi un sentiment
voilà deux
de laxisme en fait enfin d'abandon parce
que effectivement mes collègues n'ont
pas les moyens juridiques de faire leur
travail on leur interdit de faire donc
pas les moyens juridiques manque de
moyens humains et qu'il faut recruter
qu'est ce qu'il faut je pense qu'il faut
revoir aussi encore une fois les moyens
qu'on donne à la police pour agir c'est
un excellent exemple
quels sont les moyens concrets car un
policier aujourd'hui pour intervenir
dans le monde exemples que vous citez
par le contrôle d'identité il a pas
d'autres moyens d'intervenir donc on va
répéter des contrôles d'identité parce
que c'est quelque chose qu'on sait faire
techniquement et on sait les
conséquences
on génère de l'énervement donc sur quoi
il faut travailler il faut travailler
sur par exemple sur les mesures
d'éloignement temporaire c'est des
choses qui sont prévus au programme qui
vont être revus début de bd 1018 dans la
loi donc pas sur la police de sécurité
quotidienne mais sur l'aménagement de la
justice travailler sur le lien social
oui et moi je prends des exemples mettre
dix mille ce policiers supplémentaires
c'est des moyens supplémentaires par
contre il faut regarder quelle position
va m peut-être qu'un policier très
expérimenté qui a fait déjà une large
partie de sa carrière dans la police
sera bien plus opérationnels dans un
quartier dit sensible pour faire ce lien
social qui dit l'un social c'est pas
forcément pour discuter avec les jeunes
laisser faire ce lien avec les bailleurs
sociaux avec les associations de
quartiers qui sont là et c'est son
expérience qui sera nécessaire c'est pas
forcément plus de moyens ou plus de
policiers dans ce quartier là mais un
policier peut être expérimentée et qui
pourra dialoguer différemment avec la
population genia le cam
le mot de la fin sur la recette pour que
cette police de sécurité du quotidien
soit pérenne nous déjà d'avoir des
moyens humains d'éviter parce qu'en fait
on parle d'un système où depuis quelques
mois on ferme les bureaux de police faut
savoir que tous les bureaux de police
ont été fermés sur le chesnay versailles
on a regroupé plus des effectifs dans
des structures il faut savoir qu'il ya
des commissariats fantômes dans les
yvelines où vous avez le commissaire est
fontaine fleurie qui a coûté quatre
millions et demi d'euros aux
contribuables qui est vide il ya deux
collègues qui garde la structure qui est
totalement vide puisqu'il n'ya plus
d'effectifs à mettre dedans ils ont été
regroupés à plaisir donc nous on attend
des effectifs et voilà c'est urgent il
faut savoir que nous on a du mal à
monter des fois des équipages
police-secours le week-end sur certaines
agglomérations de la concertation et
c'est la même méthode que nous allons
poignet que pour sur les autres sujets
les ordonnances travail etc
on ne décide pas quelque chose en
centrale le gouvernement conserve donc
ses laisser les réunions nous allons
avoir ensemble il ya cette idée qui est
sur la table il ya des moyens
supplémentaires je les ai annoncé depuis
tout à l'heure
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
ensemble et on va pas décider nous tous
seuls qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ces
moyens supplémentaires donc de la
concertation de la fare merci à tous les
deux merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
fin du set 8 débat ce soir consacrée à
la nouvelle et prochaine police de
sécurité du quotidien l'émission est à
revoir sur notre site internet a
commenté sur les réseaux sociaux
bonne soirée à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]